welcome back to success $0.99 artificial
general intelligence today we have
Stephen Wolfram Wow
that's the first I didn't even get
started you're already clapping in his
book a new kind of science he has
explored and revealed the power beauty
and complexity of cellular automata as
simple computational systems for which
incredible complexity can emerge it's
actually one of the books that really
inspired me to get into artificial
intelligence he's created the Wolfram
Alpha competition knowledge engine
created Mathematica that has now
expanded to become Wolfram language both
he and his son were involved in helping
analyze create the alien language from
the movie arrival of which they use the
Wolfram language please again gives
Steven a warm welcome boy so I gather
the brief here is to talk about how
artificial general intelligence is going
to be achieved is that they set the
basic picture so I maybe I'm reminded of
kind of a storage I don't think I've
ever told in public but that something
that happened just a few buildings over
from here so this was 2009 and Wolfram
Alpha was was about to arrive on the
scene I assume most of you have used
wolf now for a scene wolf alpha yes the
how many of you've used wolf alpha ok
that's good so I had long been a friend
of Marvin Minsky's and Marvin was a sort
of pioneer of the AI world and I kind of
seen for years you know question
answering systems that tried to do sort
of general intelligence question
answering and so at Marvin and so I was
going to show Marvin you know Wolfram
Alpha he looks at it and he's like okay
that's fine whatever said no Marvin this
time it actually works
you can try real questions this is
actually something useful this is not
just a toy and it was kind of
interesting to see it took took about
five minutes for Marvin to realize that
this was finally a
to an answering system that could
actually answer questions that were
useful to people and so one question is
how did we how do we achieve that so you
know you go to Wolf's malphur and you
can ask it I mean it's I don't know what
we can ask it I don't know what's the
some random question what is the
population of Cambridge actually here's
a question / let's try that what's the
population of Cambridge is probably
going to figure out that we mean
Cambridge Massachusetts it's going to
give us some number it's gonna give us
some plot actually what I want to know
is number of students at MIT divided by
population of Cambridge see if it can
figure that out and okay it's kind of
interesting right oh no that's / ah
that's interesting a guest that we were
talking about Cambridge University as
the as the denominator there so it says
the number of students at MIT divided by
the number of students at Cambridge
University that's interesting I'm
actually surprised let's see what
happens if I say Cambridge MA there now
as it probably fail horribly no that's
that's good okay so no that's
interesting that's a plot as a function
of time of the fraction of the of okay
so anyway so I'm glad it works the so
one one question is how did we manage to
get so that many things have to work in
order to get stuff like this to work you
have to be able to understand the
natural language you have to have that
data sources you have to be able to
compute things from the data and so on
one of the things that was a surprise to
me was in terms of natural language
understanding was the critical thing
turned out to be just knowing a lot of
stuff the actual pausing of the natural
language is kind of I think it's kind of
clever and we use a bunch of ideas that
came from my new kind of science project
and so on but I think the most important
thing is just knowing a lot of stuff
about the world is is really important
to actually being able to to understand
natural language in a useful situation I
think the other thing is having
actually having access to lots of data
let me show you a typical example here
of what is needed so I asked about the
ISS and hopefully it'll wake up and tell
us something here come on what's going
on here there we go okay so it figured
out that we probably are talking about a
spacecraft not a file format and now
it's going to give us a plot that shows
us where the ISS is right now so to make
this work we obviously have to have some
feed of you know radar tracking data
about satellites and so on which we have
for every satellite that's that's out
there but then that's not good enough to
just have that feed then you also have
to be able to do celestial mechanics to
work out well where is the ISS actually
right now based on the orbital elements
that have been deduced from radar and
then if we want to know things like okay
when is it going to it's not currently
visible from Boston Massachusetts it
will next rise at 7:30 6:00 p.m. on
Monday on today so you know this
requires a mixture of data about what's
going on in the world together with
models about how the world is supposed
to work being able to predict things and
so on and I think another thing that
kind of realized about about AI and so
on from the wolfman alpha effort has
been that you know one of the earlier
ideas for how one would achieve AI was
let's make it work kind of like brains
do and let's make it figure stuff out
and so if it has to do physics let's
have it do physics by pure reasoning
like you know people at least used to do
physics but in the last 300 years we've
had a different way to do physics that
wasn't sort of based on natural
philosophy it was instead based on
things like mathematics and so one of
the things that we were doing in in
Wolfman alpha was to kind of cheat
relative to what had been done in
previous AI systems which was instead of
using kind of reasoning type methods
we're just saying okay we want to
compute where the ISS is going to be
well we've got a bunch of equations of
motion that corresponds to differential
equations we're just going to solve the
equations of motion and get an answer
that's kind of leveraging the last 300
years or so of
of exact science that have been done
rather than trying to make use of kind
of human reasoning ideas and I might
might say that in terms of the the
history of the wolf malphur project when
I was a kid a disgustingly a long time
ago I was interested in AI kinds of
things and I in fact I was kind of upset
recently to find a bunch of stuff I did
when I was 12 years old kind of trying
to assemble a pre version of Wolfram
Alpha way back before it was
technologically possible but it's also a
reminder that one just does the same
thing once whole life so to speak at
some level um but what happened was when
when I am I started off working mainly
in physics and then I got involved in
building computer systems to do things
like mathematical computation and so on
and I then sort of got interested in
okay so can we generalize this stuff and
can we can we really make systems that
can answer sort of arbitrary questions
about the world and for example sort of
the the the the promise would be if
there's something that is systematically
known in our civilization make it
automatic to answer questions on the
basis of that systematic knowledge and
back in the in around late 1970s early
1980s my conclusion was if you want to
do something like that the only
realistic path to being able to do it
was to build something much like a brain
and so I got interested in neural nets
and I tried to do things with neural
nets back in 1980 and nothing very
interesting happened well I couldn't get
him to do anything very interesting and
that um so I kind of had the idea that
that the only way to get the kind of
thing that now exists in alpha for
example was to build a brain like thing
and then many years later for reasons I
can explain I kind of came back to this
and realized actually it wasn't true
that you had to build a brain like
things sort of mere computation was
sufficient and that was kind of what got
me started actually trying to build
Wolfram Alpha when we started building
wolf malphur one of these I did was go
to a sort of a field trip to a big
reference library and you know you see
all these shelves of books and so on and
the question is can we take all of this
knowledge that exists in all of these
books and actually automate being able
to answer questions on the base
Javad and I think we've pretty much done
that for that at least the books you
find in a typical reference library so
that was it looked kind of daunting at
the beginning because it's this there's
a lot of knowledge and information out
there but actually it turns out there
are a few thousand domains and we've
steadily gone through and worked on
these different domains another feature
of the worth mouthful project was that
we didn't really you know I've been
involved a lot in doing basic science
and in trying to have sort of grand
theories of the world one of my
principles in building Wolfram Alpha was
not to start from a grand theory of the
world that is not to kind of start from
some global ontology of the world and
then try and build down into all these
different domains but instead to work up
from having you know hundreds then
thousands of domains that actually work
whether they're you know information
about cars or information about sports
or information about movies or whatever
else how each of these domains sort of
building up from the bottom in each of
these domains and then finding that
there were common themes in these
domains that we could then build into
frameworks and then sort of construct
the whole system on the basis of that
and that's kind of that's kind of how
its worked and I can talk about some of
the actual frameworks that we end up
using and so on but maybe I should
explain a little bit more so so one
question is how does how does Wolf's
mouth actually sort of work inside and
the answer is it's a big program it's
about it's the core system is about 15
million lines of Wolfram language code
and it's some number of terabytes of raw
data and so the the way the thing that
sort of made building wolf now for
possible was this language wolf and
language which started with Mathematica
which came out in 1988 and has been sort
of progressively growing since then so
maybe I should show you some things
about both language and and you know
it's easy you can you know use this mit
has a site license for it you can use it
all over the places you can find it on
the web but cetera etc etc but okay
the basics work the let's let's start
off with something like let's make a
random graph and let's say we have
a random graph with two hundred nodes
400 vertices okay so there's a random
graph a first important thing about
wolfing language is it's a symbolic
language so I can just pick up this
graph and I could say you know I don't
do some analysis of this graph that
graph is just a symbolic thing that I
can just do computations on oh I could
say let's let's get a another good thing
to always do is get a current image see
there we go and now I could go and say
something like let's let's do some basic
thing let's say let's edgy detect that
image again this this image is just a a
thing that we can manipulate we could
take the image we could make it I don't
know we could take the image and
partition it little pieces do
computations on that I don't know simple
let's do let's just say sort each row of
the image assemble the image again
whoops assemble that image again we'll
get some some mixed up picture there if
I wanted to I could for example let's
say let's make that the current image
and let's say make that dynamic now I
can be just running that code hopefully
and little loop and there we can make
that work so the you know one one
general point here is there's you know
this is just an image for us is just a
piece of data like anything else if we
just have a variable a thing called X it
just says okay that's X I don't need to
know particular value it's just a
symbolic thing the corresponds to that's
a thing called X now you know what gets
interesting when you have a symbolic
language and so on is we're interested
in having it represent stuff about the
world as well as just abstract kinds of
things that many you know I can
abstractly say you know find some funky
integral I don't know what you know
that's then representing using symbolic
variables to represent algebraic kinds
of things but I could also just say I
don't know something like Boston and
Boston is another kind of symbolic thing
that has if I say what what is it really
inside that's it's the
today a City Boston Massachusetts United
States actually noticed when I type that
in I was using natural language to type
it in and it gave me a bunch of
disambiguation here it said assuming
Boston is a city assuming Boston
Massachusetts use Boston New York or
okay there's let's use let's use Boston
and the Philippines which I've never
heard of but but um let's try using that
instead and now if I look at that it'll
say it's Boston in some province of the
Philippines etc etc now I might ask it
of that I could say something like
what's the population of that and it um
okay it's a fairly small place or I
could say for example let me let me do
this let me say a geo list plot from
that Boston
let's take from that Boston - and now
let's type in Boston again and now let's
have it used the default meaning of the
word of Boston and then let's join those
up and now this should plot this should
show me a plot there we go okay so
there's the path from the Boston that we
picked in the Philippines to the Boston
here oh we could ask you don't know I
could just say I could ask it the
distance from one to another or
something like that so the the one of
the things here one things we found
really really useful actually in
language was first of all there's a way
of representing stuff about the world
like cities for example or let's say I
want to say let's let's do this let's
say let's do something with cities let's
say capital cities in South America okay
so notice this is a piece of natural
language this will get interpreted into
something which is precise symbolic
wolfram language code that we can then
compute with and that will give us the
citizens out the capital cities in South
America I could for example let's say I
say find shortest to US and I'm going to
use some some oops no I don't want to do
that what I want to do first is to say
show me the geo positions of all those
cities on line 21 there so now it will
find the geo positions and now it will
say compute the shortest tour
so that's saying there's a 10,000 mile
traveling salesman tour around those
cities so I could take those cities were
on line 21 and I could say order the
cities according to this and then I
could make another geo list plot of that
join it up and this should now show us a
traveling salesman tour of the of the
capital cities in South America um so
you know it's it's sort of interesting
to see what's involved in making stuff
like this work the one of you know my my
goal has been to sort of automate as
much as possible about things that have
to be computed and that means knowing as
many algorithms as possible and also
knowing as much data about the world as
possible and I kind of view this as sort
of a knowledge-based programming
approach where you have you know a
typical kind of idea in programming
languages is you know you have some
small programming languages has a few
primitives that are pretty much tied
into what a machine can intrinsically do
and then maybe you'll have libraries
that add on to that and so on
my kind of crazy idea of many many years
ago has been to build an integrated
system where all of the stuff about
different domains of knowledge and so on
are all just built into the system and
and designed in a coherent way I mean
this has been kind of the story of my
life for the last thirty years is trying
to keep the design of the system
coherent even as one adds all sorts of
different areas of of capability so as
some I mean we can go and dive into all
sorts of different kinds of things here
but maybe as an example well let's do
what could we do here we could take come
let's try how about this is that a bone
I think so that's a bone so let's try
that as a mesh region see if that works
so this will now use a completely
different domain of human endeavor okay
oops there's two of those bones let's
try let's just try them let's try
humorous let's try the that the mesh
region for that and now we should have a
bone here okay there's a there's a
representation of a bone let's take that
bone and we could for example say let's
take the surface area of that as in some
some units or I could let's do some much
more outrageous thing let's say we take
region distance so we're going to take
the distance from some from that bone to
a point let's say 0 0 Z and let's make a
plot of that distance with Z going from
let's say I don't have no idea where the
where the spawn is but let's try
something like this so that was really
boring um let's try them so what this is
doing again a whole bunch of stuff has
to work in order for this to operate
this has to be this is a this is some
region in 3d space that's represented by
some mesh you have to compute you know
do the computational geometry to figure
out where it is if I want it to let's
try anatomy anatomy plot 3d and let's
say something like left hand for example
and now it's going to show us probably
the complete data that it has about the
geometry of the left hand there we go ok
so there's there's the results and we
could take that apart and start
computing things from it and so on so
what um so this this is some so there's
a there's a lot of kind of computational
knowledge that's built in here one let's
talk a little bit about kind of the
modern machine learning story so for
instance if I say let's get a picture
here let's say um let's let's just say
picture of symbol got a favorite kind of
animal what's Panda okay so let's try ok
giant panda
okay okay there's a panda let's see what
now let's try saying um let's try for
this panda let's try saying image
identify and now here we'll be
embarrassed probably but let's just see
let's see what happens if I say image
identify that and now it'll hopefully
wake up wake up wake up this only takes
a few hundred milliseconds
okay very good giant panda let's let's
see what it's we'll see what the
runners-up were to the giant panda let's
say we want to say the ten runners-up in
all categories for that thing okay so a
giant panda a prop here Ned which I've
never heard of are pandas carniverous
ate bamboo shoots okay so that was so
lucky I didn't get that one it's really
sure it's a mammal and it's absolutely
certain it's a vertebrate okay so you
might ask how did it figure this out and
so then you can kind of look under the
hood and say so we have a whole
framework for representing neural nets
symbolically and so this is the actual
model that it's using to do this so this
is a so there's a neural net and it's
got we can drill down and we can see
there's there's a piece of the neuron
that we can drill down even further to
one of these and we can probably see
what that's a batch normalization layer
somewhere deep deep inside the entrails
of the not panda but of this thing okay
so now let's take that object which is
just a symbolic object and let's feed it
the picture of the Panda and we can see
and there oops I was not giving it the
right thing what did I just do wrong
here okay let's let's take our isolated
okay let's take this thing and feed it
the picture of the Panda and it says a
giant panda okay how about we do
something more outrageous let's take
that neuron that and let's only use the
first let's say 10 layers of the neuron
that so let's just take out 10 layers of
the neuron that's and feed it the Panda
and now what we'll get is something from
the insides of the neuron that and I
could say for example let's just make
those into images okay so that's what
that's what the neuron that
had figured out about the Panda after 10
layers of going through the neuron that
and maybe actually be interesting to see
let's do a feature space plots and now
we're going to of those intermediate
things in the sort of in the brain of
the neuron that sort of speak this is
now taking so what this is just doing is
to do dimension reduction on this space
of images and so it's not very exciting
it's probably mostly distinguishing
these by total gray level but that's
kind of showing us the space of of
different ton of different sort of
features of the insides of the Shinra on
that so it's also what's interesting to
see here is things like the symbolic
representation of the neuron that's and
if you if you're wondering how does that
hatch will work inside it's underneath
it's using a max net which we happen to
have contributed to a lot and there's
sort of a bunch of symbolic layers on
top of that that feed into that and
maybe I can show you here let me show
you how you would train one of these
neural nets that's also kind of fun so
we have a data repository that has all
sorts of useful data one piece of data
it has is a bunch of neuron that
training sets so this is a standard emne
straining set of handwritten digits
okay so there's m missed and you notice
that these things here that's just an
image which i could copy out and i could
do you know let's say I could do color
negate on that image because it's just
an image and there's there's the results
and so on and now I could say let's take
let's take a neuron that like let's take
a simple neuron that like Linette for
example okay so let's take Linette and
then let's take the untrained initial
evaluation Network so this is now a
version of Linette simple standard
neural nets that didn't get trained so
for example if I if I take that that
symbolic representation of Lynette and I
could say net initialize then it will
take that and it'll just put random
weights into Lynette okay so if I take
those random weights and I feed it a
zero here I feed it that image of a zero
it will presumably produce something
completely random in this particular
case - right so now now what I would
like to do is to take this so that was
just randomly initializing the weights
so now what I'd like to do is to take
the emne straining set and I'd like to
actually train Lynette using MMS
training set so let's take let's take
this and let's take a random sample of
let's say I don't know a thousand pieces
of Lynette come on why is it having to
load it again there we go okay so
there's a there's a random sample there
was on line 21 and now let me go down
here and say where was it well look we
can just take this this thing here so
this is the uninitialized version of
Lynette and we can say take that and
then let's say net train of that with
the thing on line 21 which was that
thousand instances so now what it's
doing is its running training on and
that's you see the loss going down and
so on it's running training for for
those thousand instances of Lynette and
it will we can stop it if we want to
actually this is a new display this is
very nice
this is this is a new version of both
languages is coming out next week which
I'm showing you but it's quite similar
to what exists today but because that's
one of the features of running a
software company is that you always run
the the very latest version of things
for better or worse and that's and this
is also a good way to debug it because
supposed to come out next week if I find
some horrifying bug maybe it will get
delayed but let's try them let's sum
let's try this okay now it says it's
zero okay
and so so this is now a trained version
of Lynette trained with that with that
training data um one of the things so
you know we can talk about all kinds of
details of your mats and so on but maybe
I should zoom out to talk a little bit
about bigger picture as I see it so one
question is sort of a question of what
is in principle possible to do with
computation so you know we have as we're
you know we're building all kinds of
things we're making image identifies
we're figuring out those kinds of things
about where the International Space
Station is and so on question is what is
what is in principle
possible to compute and so the you know
one of the places one can ask that
question is when one looks at for
example models of the natural world one
can say you know how do we make models
of the natural world kind of a a
traditional approach has been let's use
mathematical equations to make models of
the natural world a question is if we
want to kind of generalize that and say
well what are all possible ways to make
models of things what can we say about
that question so I spent many years of
my life trying to address that question
and basically what what I've thought
about a lot is that if you want to make
a model of a thing you have to have
definite rules by which the thing
operates what's the most general way to
represent possible rules well in today's
world we think of that as a program so
the next question is well what does the
space of all possible programs look like
and most of the time you know we're
writing programs like Wolfen language is
50 million lines of code and it's a big
complicated program that was for built
for a fairly specific purpose but the
question is if we just look at sort of
the space of possible programs more or
less at random what's out there in the
space of possible program so I got an
interest in many years ago in cellular
automata which are a really good example
of a very simple kind of program so let
me show you an example of one of these
so this is these are the rules for a
typical cellular automaton and this just
says you have a row of black and white
squares and this just says you look at a
black a look at a square say what color
is that square what color left or it's
left and right neighbors decide what
color the square will be on the next
step based on that rule okay so really
simple rule so now let's let's take a
look at what what actually happens if we
use that rule a bunch of times so we can
take that rule the 254 is just the
binary digits that correspond to those
positions in this rule so now I can say
this I could say let's do 50 steps let
me do this sum and now if I run
according to the rule I just defined it
turns out to be pretty trivial it's just
saying if any if any square is if we
start off with a black square if any
square is if any neighboring square is
black make a black square so we've we've
used a very simple program
we've got a very simple results out okay
let's try a different program we can try
changing this we'll get some that's a
program with one bit different now we
get that kind of pattern so the question
is well what happens you might say okay
if you've got such a trivial program
it's not surprising you're just going to
get Trevor a results out so but you can
do an experiment to test that hypothesis
you can just say let's take all possible
programs there are 256 possible programs
that are based on these eight bits here
let's just take well let's just whoops
let's just take come let's say the first
64 of those programs and let's just make
a echo let's just make a table of the
results that we get by running those
first 64 programs here so here we get
the result and what you see is well most
of them are pretty trivially the lake
they start off with one black cell in
the middle and it just tools after one
side occasionally we get something more
exciting happening like here's a nice
nested pattern that we get if we were to
continue it longer it would it would
make you know more detailed nesting but
then my all-time favorite science
discovery if you go on and just look at
these after a while you find this one
here which is rule 30 in this in this
numbering scheme and that's doing
something a bit more complicated you say
well what's going on here you know we
just started off with this very simple
rule let's see what happens maybe after
a while you know if we run rule 30 long
enough it will resolve into something
simpler so let's try running it let's
say 500 steps and that's the whoops
that's the result we get I'd say let's
just make it fullscreen okay
it's aliasing a bit on the projector
there but but you get the basic idea
this is a so this just started off from
one black cell at the top and this is
what it made and that's pretty weird
because all this is you know this is
sort of not the way it's supposed things
are supposed to work because what we
have here is just that little program
down there and it makes this big
complicated pattern here and you know we
can see there's a certain amount of
regularity on one side but for example
the center column
this pattern is for all practical
purposes completely random in fact it
was reused as a random number generator
in Mathematica and Wolfram language for
many years it was recently retired after
after excellent service because we found
a somewhat more efficient one um
the but the so you know what do we learn
from this what we learn from this is out
in the computational universe of
possible programs it's possible to get
even with very simple programs very rich
complicated behavior well that's
important if you're interested in
modeling the natural world because you
might think that there are programs that
represent systems in nature that might
work this way and so on it's also
important for technology because it says
ok let's say you're trying to find a
let's say you're trying to find a
program that's a good random number
generator how are you going to do that
well you could start thinking very hard
and you could try makeup you know you
could try and write down all kinds of
flowcharts about how this random number
generator is going to work or you can
say forget that I'm just going to search
the computational universe for possible
programs and just look for one that
serves as a good random number generator
in this particular case after you've
searched 30 programs you'll find one
that makes a good random number
generator why does it work that's a
complicated story it's not a story that
I think necessarily we can really tell
very well but what's important is that
this is this idea that out in the
computational universe there's a lot of
rich sophisticated stuff that can be
essentially mind for our technological
purposes that's the important thing
whether we understand how this works is
a different matter I mean it's like when
we look at the natural world the
physical world were used to kind of
mining things you know we started using
magnets to do magnetic stuff long before
we understand understood the theory of
ferromagnetism and so on and so
similarly here we can sort of go out
into the computational universe and find
stuff that's useful for our purposes now
in fact the world of sort of deep
learning and neural nets and so on is a
little bit like this it uses the trick
that there's a certain degree of
differentiability there so you can kind
of home in on let's try and find
something that's incremental II better
and for certain kinds of problems that
works pretty well
I think the thing that we've done a lot
I've done a lot it's just sort of
exhaustive search in the computational
universe of possible programs just
search of trillion programs and try and
find one that does something interesting
and useful for you um there's a lot of
things to say about what well actually
in in these search of trillion programs
and find one that's useful let me show
you another example of that um see so I
was interested a while ago in the I have
to look something up here sorry um in C
in boolean algebra and in I was
interested in in the space of all
possible mathematic says um and let me
just see here I I'm not finding what I
wanted to find sorry I was a good
example I should have memorized this but
I haven't so um there we go there it is
um so I was interested in if you just
look at so we talked about sort of
looking at the space of all possible the
space of all possible programs another
thing you can do is say if you're going
to invent mathematics from nothing what
possible axiom systems could be used in
mathematics so I was curious where do
and that again might seem like a
completely crazy thing to do to just say
let's just start enumerate axiom systems
at random and see if we find one that's
interesting and useful but it turns out
once you have this idea that out in the
computational universe or possible
programs there's actually a lot of
low-hanging fruit to be found it turns
out you can apply that in lots of places
I mean the thing to understand is why
why do we not see a lot of engineering
structures that look like this the
reason is because our traditional model
of engineering has been we engineer
things in a way where we where we can
foresee what the outcome of our
engineering steps are going to be and
when it comes to something like this we
can find it out in the computational
universe what we can't readily foresee
what's going to happen we can't do sort
of a step by step design
of this particular thing and so in
engineering and human engineering as
it's been practiced so far most of it
has consisted of building things where
we can foresee step by step what the
outcome of our engineering going to be
and we see that in programs we see that
in other kinds of engineering structures
and so there's sort of a different kind
of engineering which is about mining the
computational universe of possible
programs and it's worth realizing
there's a lot more that can be done a
lot more efficiently by mining the
computational universe of possible
programs than by just constructing
things step by step as a human so for
example if you look for optimal
algorithms for things like I don't know
even something like sorting networks the
optimal sorting networks look very
complicated they're not things that you
would construct by sort of step-by-step
thinking about things with in a kind of
in a kind of typical human way and so
this this idea you know if you're really
going to have computation work
efficiently you are going to end up with
these programs that are sort of just
mined from the computational universe
and one of the issues with mining things
so they're there this makes use of
computation much more efficiently than a
typical thing that we might construct
now one feature of this is it's hard to
understand what's going on and there's
actually a fundamental reason for that
which is in our efforts to sort of
understand what's going on we get to use
our brains our computers our mathematics
or whatever and our goal is this this
particular little program did a certain
amount of computation to work out this
pattern the question is can we kind of
outrun that computation and say oh I can
tell that actually this particular bit
down here is going to be a black black
bit you don't have to go and do all that
computation but it turns out that then
again this will maybe as a digression
which which there's this phenomenon I
call computational irreducibility which
i think is really common and it's a
consequence of this thing I call
principle of computational equivalence
and that the principle of computational
equivalence basically says as soon as
you have a system whose behavior isn't
fairly easy to analyze the chances are
that the computation it's doing is
essentially as sophisticated as it could
be and that has consequences like it
implies that the typical thing like
this will correspond to a universal
computer that you can use to program
anything it also has the consequence of
this computational irreducibility
phenomenon that says you can't expect
our brains to be able to outrun the
computations that are going on inside
the system if there was computational
reducibility then we can expect that
this thing went to a lot of trouble and
did a million steps of evolution but
actually just by using our brains we can
jump ahead and see what the answer will
be computational irreducibility suggests
that isn't the case if we're going to
make the most efficient use of
computational resources we will
inevitably run into computational
irreducibility all over the place it has
the consequence that we get the
situation where we can't readily sort of
foresee and understand what's going to
happen so back to mathematics for a
second so this is just an axiom system
that so I looked for all possible look
through sort of all possible axiom
systems starting off with very really
tiny ones and I asked the question
what's the first axiom system that
corresponds to boolean algebra so it
turns out this this thing here this tiny
little thing here generates all theorems
of boolean algebra it is that it is the
simplest axiom for boolean algebra now
something I have to show you this
because it's a new feature you see they
um if I say find equation or proof let's
say I want to prove commutativity of the
NAND operation I'm going to show you
something here this is going to try to
generate let's see if this works this is
going to try to generate an automated
proof based on that axiom system of that
result so it had 102 steps in the proof
and let's try and say let's look at for
example the proof network here actually
let's look at the proof data set um now
that's not what I wanted I should learn
how to use this shouldn't I um let's see
what I want is the you know proof data
set there we go very good ok so this is
actually let's let's say first of all
let's say the proof graph ok so this is
going to show me the how that proof was
done so
they're a bunch of lemmas that got
proved and from those lemmas those
lemmas were combined and eventually it
proved the result so let's let's take a
look at the let's take a look at what
some of those llamas were okay so here's
the results so after so it goes through
and these are various lemmas it's using
and eventually after many pages of
nonsense it will get to the result okay
each one of these some of these llamas
are kind of complicated there that's
that's that llama it's a pretty
complicated lemma etc etcetera etcetera
so you might ask what on earth is going
on here and the answer is so I first
generated a version of this proof 20
years ago and I tried to understand what
was going on and I completely failed and
it's sort of embarrassing because this
is supposed to be a proof it's supposed
to be you know demonstrating some
results and what we realize is that you
know what does it mean to have a proof
of something what does it mean to
explain how a thing is done you know
what is the purpose of a proof purpose
of a proof is basically to let humans
understand why something is true and so
for example if you go to let's say we go
to wolf now fur and we do you know some
random thing where we say let's do you
know an integral of something or another
it will be able to very quickly in fact
it will take it only milliseconds
internally to work out the answer to
that integral okay but then somebody
whose wants to hand in a piece of
homework or something like that needs to
explain why is this true okay well we
have this handy step-by-step solution
thing here which
explains why it's true now the thing I
should admit about the step-by-step
solution is it's completely fake that is
the steps that are described in the step
by step solution have absolutely nothing
to do with the way that internally that
integral was computed these are steps
created purely for the purpose of
telling a story to humans about why this
integral came out the way it did and now
what we're seeing and so that's a so
that's one thing is knowing the answer
the other thing is being able to tell a
story about why the answer worked that
way
well what we see here is this is a proof
but it was an automatically generated
proof and it's a really lousy story for
us humans I mean if it turned out that
one of these theorems here was one that
had been proved by Gauss or something
and appeared in all the textbooks we
would be much happier because then we
would start to have a kind of human
representable story about what was going
on instead we just get a bunch of
machine generated lemmas that we can't
understand that we can't kind of wrap
our brains around and it's sort of the
same thing that's going on in when we
look at when these neural nets we're
seeing you know when we were looking
wherever it was at the innards of that
neuron that and we say well how is it
figuring out that that's a picture of a
panda well the answer is it decided that
you know if we humans were saying how
would you figure out if it's a picture
of panda we might say well look and see
if it has eyes that's a clue for whether
it's an animal look and see if it's
looks like it's kind of round and furry
and things that's a version of whether
it's a panda and Len cetera etcetera
etcetera but what it's doing is it
learnt a bunch of criteria for you know
is it a panda or is it one of 10,000
other possible things that it could have
recognized and it learnt those criteria
in a way that was somehow optimal based
on the training that it got and so on
but it learnt things which were
distinctions which are different from
the distinctions that we humans make in
the language that we as humans use and
so in some sense you know when we start
talking about will describe a picture we
have a certain human language for
describing that picture we have you know
in our human in typical human languages
we have maybe thirty to fifty thousand
words that we use to describe things
those words are words that have sort of
evolved as being useful for describing
the world that we live in
um when it comes to there's known that
it could be using it could say well that
the words that it is effectively learnt
which allow it to make distinctions
about what's going on in the in the
analysis that it's doing it has
effectively invented words that describe
distinctions but those words have
nothing to do with our historically
invented words that exist in our
languages so it's kind of an interesting
situation that that it is its way of
thinking so to speak if you say well
what's it thinking about how do we
describe what it's thinking that's a
tough thing to answer because just like
with the with the automated theorem
we're we're sort of stuck having to say
well we can't really tell a human story
because the things that it invented are
things for which we don't even have
words in our languages and so on okay so
one thing to realize is in this kind of
space of sort of all possible
computations there's a lot of stuff out
there that can be done there's this kind
of ocean of sophisticated computation
and then the question that we have to
ask for us humans is okay how do we make
use of all of that stuff so what we've
got kind of on the one hand is we've got
the things we know how to think about
human language is our way of describing
things our way of talking about stuff
that's the one one set of things the
other set of things we have is this very
powerful kind of seething ocean of
computation on the other side where lots
of things can happen so the question is
how do we make use of this sort of ocean
of computation in the best possible way
for our human purposes and building
technology and so on and so the the way
I see you know my kind of part of what
I've spent a very long time doing is
kind of building a language that allows
us to take human thinking on the one
hand and describe and sort of provide a
sort of computational communication
language that allows us to get the
benefit of what's possible over in the
sort of ocean of computation in a way
that's rooted in what we humans actually
want to do and so I kind of view both
from language as being sort of an
attempt to make a bridge between so you
on the one hand there's all possible
computations on the other hand there's
things we think we want to do and I view
or from language as being my best
attempt right now to make a way to take
our sort of human computational thinking
and be able to actually implement it so
in a sense it's a language which works
in two on two sides it's both a language
where you as a as a the machine can
understand okay it's it's looking at
this and that's what it's going to
compute but on the other hand it's also
a language for us humans to think about
things in computational terms so you
know if I go and I don't know one of
these one of these things that I'm doing
here whatever it is that this wasn't
that exciting but but you know fine
shortest tour of the Geo position of the
capital cities in South America that is
a language that's a representation in a
precise language of something and the
idea is that that's a language which we
humans can find useful in thinking about
things in computational terms it also
happens to be a language that the
machine can immediately understand and
execute and so I think this is sort of a
general you know when I think about AI
in general the you know what is the sort
of what's the overall problem well part
of the overall problem is so how do we
tell the AI is what to do so to speak
there's this very powerful you know this
sort of ocean of computation is what we
get to mine for purposes of building AI
kinds of things but then the question is
how do we tell the AI is what to do and
the what I see what I've tried to do
with Wolfram language is to provide a a
way of kind of accessing that
computation and sort of making use of
the knowledge that our civilization has
accumulated and because that's the you
know there's the general computation on
on this side and there's the specific
things that we humans have thought about
and the question is to make use of the
things that we've thought about to do do
things that we care about doing actually
if you're interested in these kinds of
things I happen to just write a blog
post where last couple of days ago it's
kind
the funny blog posts it's about some but
you can see the title there it came
because a friend of miners has this
crazy project to put little little sort
of discs or something that should
represent kind of the best achievements
of human civilization so to speak to
send out it's it's hitchhiking on
various spacecraft that are going out
into the solar system in the next little
while and the question is what to put on
this little disc that kind of represents
you know the achievements of
civilization it's kind of it's kind of
depressing when you go back and you look
at what some what people have tried to
do on this before and realizing how hard
it is to tell even whether something is
an artifact or not but this is this was
sort of a yeah that's a good one that's
from 11,000 years ago can you the
question is can you figure out what on
earth it is and what it means and and
this is but but so what what's relevant
about this is the this this whole
question of there are things that are
out there in the computational universe
and you know when we think about
extraterrestrial intelligence I find it
kind of interesting that artificial
intelligence is our first example of an
alien intelligence we don't happen to
have found what we view as
extraterrestrial intelligence right now
but we are in the process of building
pretty decent version of an alien
intelligence here and the question is if
you ask questions like well you know
what is it thinking is it does it have a
purpose and what it's doing and so on
and you're confronted with things like
this it's very we you can kind of do a
test run of you know what's what's its
purpose what is it trying to do in a way
that is very similar to the kinds of
questions you would ask about about
extraterrestrial intelligence but in
case the the that the main point is that
I see this sort of ocean of computation
there's the let's describe what we
actually want to do with that ocean of
computation and that's where you know
that's one of the primary problems we
have now people talk about you know AI
and what is AI going to allow us to
automate and my basic answer that would
be we'll be able to automate everything
that we can describe the problem is
it's not clear what we can describe or
put another way you know you imagine
various jobs and people are doing things
they're repeated judgment jobs things
like this there where we can readily
automate those things but the thing that
we can't really automate is saying well
what are we trying to do that is what
are our goals because in a sense when
when we see one of these systems you
know let's say let's say it's a cellular
tartan here okay the question is what is
this cellular automaton trying to do
maybe I can maybe I'll give you another
cellular automaton that is a little bit
more exciting here let's do this one so
that the the question is what is this
cellular automaton trying to do you know
it's got this whole big structure here
and things are happening with it we can
go we can run it for a couple thousand
steps we can ask it's a nice example of
kind of undecidability in action what's
going to happen here this is kind of the
halting problem is this going to halt
what's it going to do
there's computational irreducibility so
we actually can't tell this is the case
where we know this is a universal
computer in fact eventually well I don't
even spoil it for you if I went on long
enough it would it would go into some
kind of cycle but um we can ask what is
this thing trying to do what is it you
know is it what's it thinking about
what's its um
you know what's its goal what's its
purpose and you know we get very quickly
in a big mess thinking about those kinds
of things I've one of the things that
comes out of this principle of
computational equivalence is thinking
about what kinds of things have are
capable of sophisticated computation so
so I mentioned a while back here sort of
my personal history with Wolff malphur
of having thought about doing something
like wolf now for when I was a kid and
then believing that you sort of had to
build a brain to make that possible and
so on and one of the things that I then
thought was that there was some kind of
bright line between what is intelligent
and what is merely computational so to
speak in other words that there was
something which is like oh we've got
this great thing that we humans have
that you know as intelligence and all
these things in nature and so on and all
the stuff that's going on it's just
computation or it's just you know things
operating according to rules that's
different there's some bright line
distinction
doing these things well I think the
thing that came about after I'd looked
at all these cellular automata and all
kinds of other things like that
is I sort of came up with this principle
of computational equivalence idea which
we've now got quite a lot of evidence
for which I talked about people are
interested in but that basically there
isn't a that once you reach a certain
level of of computational sophistication
everything is equivalent and that means
that that implies that there really
isn't a bright line distinction between
for example the computations going on in
our brains and the computations going on
in these simple cellular automata and so
on and that essentially philosophical
point is what actually got me to start
trying to build both malphur because I
realized that gosh you know I've been
looking for this sort of the the magic
bullet of intelligence and I just
decided probably there isn't one and
actually it's all just computation and
so that means we can actually
impractical
intelligent like thing and so that's
what I think is the case is that there
really isn't sort of a bright line
distinction and that has that has more
extreme consequences like people will
say things like you know the weather has
a mind of its own okay
sounds kind of silly sounds kind of
animistic primitive and so on but in
fact the you know fluid dynamics of the
weather is as computationally
sophisticated as the stuff that goes on
in our brains but we can start asking
but then you say but the weather doesn't
have a purpose you know what's the
purpose of the weather well you know
maybe the weather is trying to equalize
the temperature between the you know the
the North Pole and the tropics or
something and then we have to say well
but that's not a purpose in the way that
we think about purposes that's just you
know and we get very confused and in the
end what we realize is when we're
talking about things like purposes we
have to have this kind of chain of
provenance that goes back to humans and
human history and all that kind of thing
and I think it's the same type of thing
when we talk about computation and AI
and so on the thing that we this
question of sort of purpose goals things
like this that's a thing which is
intrinsically human and not something
that we can ever sort of automatically
generate it makes no sense to talk about
automatically generating it
because these computational systems they
do all kinds of stuff you know we can
say they've got a purpose we can
attribute purposes to them etcetera
etcetera etcetera
but you know ultimately it's sort of the
human thread of purpose that we have to
have to deal with so that means for
example when we talk about AIS and we
were interested in things like so how do
we tell you know like like we'd like to
be able to tell we talk about AI ethics
for example we'd like to be able to make
a statement to the AIS like you know
please be nice to us humans um and
that's a you know that's something so
one of the issues there is so talking
about that kind of thing one of the
issues is how are we going to make a
statement like be nice to us humans
what's the you know in how are we going
to explain that to an AI and this is
where again you know my my efforts to
build a language a computational
communication language that bridges the
world of what we humans think about and
the world of what is possible in
computation is important and so one of
things I've been interested in is
actually building what I call a symbolic
discourse language that can be a general
representation for sort of the kinds of
things that we might want to put in that
we might want to to say and things like
be nice to him and so sort of a little
bit background to that so you know in
the modern world people are keen on
smart contracts they often think of them
as being deeply tied into blockchain
which I don't think is really quite
right
the important thing about smart
contracts is it's a way of having sort
of an agreement between parties which
can be executed automatically and that
agreement may be you know you may choose
to sort of anchor that agreement in a
blockchain you may not but the whole
point is you have to what you you know
when people write legal contracts they
write them in an approximation to
English they write them in legalese
typically because they're trying to
write them in something a little bit
more precise than regular English but
the limiting case of that is to make a
symbolic discourse language in which you
can write the contract and code
basically and the the I've been very
interested in using wolfmann language to
do that because in wolfen language we
have a language which Candice
bribe things about the world and we can
talk about the kinds of things that
people actually talk about in contracts
and so on and we're most of the way
there to being able to do that and then
when you start thinking about that you
start thinking about okay so we've got
this language to describe things that we
that we care about in the world and so
when it comes to things like tell the
AIS to be nice to the humans we can
imagine using often language to sort of
build an AI Constitution that says this
is how the AI supposed to work but when
we talk about sort of just the the
untethered you know the untethered AI
doesn't have any particular it's just
going to do what it does and if we want
it to you know if we want to somehow
align it with human purposes we have to
have some way to sort of talk to the AI
and that's that's a you know I view my
efforts to build or from language as as
a way to do that I mean I you know as I
was showing at the beginning you can use
you can take natural language and with
natural language you can build up a
certain amount of you can say a certain
number of things in natural language you
can then say well how do we make this
more precise in a precise symbolic
language if you want to build up more
complicated things it gets hard to do
that in natural language and so you have
to kind of build up more serious
programs in in in symbolic language and
I've probably been numb been yakking a
while here
and I'm happy to I can talk about all
kinds of different things here but that
maybe I've not seen as many reactions as
I might have expected to think so I I'm
not sure which things people are
interested in which they're not but so
maybe I should maybe I should stop here
and we can have discussion questions
comments yes
[Applause]
if two microphones if you have questions
please come out so I have a quick
question it's goes to the earlier part
of your talk where you say you don't
build a top-down ontology you actually
build from the bottom up but disparate
domains what do you feel are the core
technologies of the knowledge
representation which you use within
Wolfram Alpha that allows you you know
different domains to reason about each
other to come up with solutions and is
there any feeling of differentiability
for examples if you were to come up with
a plan to do something new within
Wolfram Alpha language you know how
would you go about doing that me okay so
we've done maybe a couple of thousand
domains okay the what is actually
involved in doing one of these domains
it's it's a gnarly business every domain
has some crazy different thing about it
I tried to make up actually a while ago
we um let me show you something a kind
of a hierarchy of what it means to make
um see if I can find this here kind of a
hierarchy of what it means to make a
domain computable where is it that's
okay here we go so there's sort of a
hierarchy of levels of what it means to
make a domain computable from just you
know you've got some you know you've got
some array of data that's quite
structured forget you know the separate
issue about extracting things from
unstructured data but let's imagine that
you were given you know a a bunch of
data about landing sites of meteorites
or something okay so you go through
various levels so you know things like
okay the landing sites the meteorites
are the are the positions just strings
or they some kind of canonical
representation of geo position is the
you know is the type of meteorite you
know some of them are iron meteorites
some of them are stone meteorites have
you made a canonical representation have
you made some kind of way to to identify
what some sorry go ahead no no I mean to
do that so my question is like you know
if you did have positions as a string as
well as a canonical representation do
you have redundant
pieces of the same redundant
representations of the same information
in the different no I mean I'll go you
always everything canonical that you
have yeah I have a minimal
representation of everything yeah our
goal is to make everything canonical now
that's you know there is a lot of
complexity in doing that I mean if you
you know in each okay so another feature
of these domains
okay so there's another another thing to
say um you know it will be lovely if one
could just automate everything and cut
the humans out of the loop
turns out this doesn't work and in fact
whenever we do these domains it's fairly
critical to have expert humans who
really understand the domain or you
simply get it wrong and it's also having
said that once you've done enough
domains you can do a lot of cross
checking between domains and we are the
number one reporters of error and of
errors and in pretty much all
standardized data sources because we can
do that kind of cross checking but I
think you know if you ask the question
what's involved in in bringing online a
new domain it's you know those sort of
hierarchy of things you know some of
those take a few hours you can get to
the point of of having you know we've
got good enough tools for ingesting data
figuring out oh those are names of
cities in that column let's you know
that's canonicalized those you know some
may be questions but many of them will
be able to to nail down and to get to
the full level of you've got some
complicated domain and it's fully
computable is probably a year of work
and and you might say well gosh why are
you wasting you their time you've got to
be able to automate that so you can
probably tell we're fairly sophisticated
about machine learning kinds of things
and so on and we have tried you know to
automate as much as we can and we have
got a pretty efficient pipeline but if
you actually want to get it right and
you see it is an example of what what
happens that there's a level even going
between wolf now for more from language
there's a level of so for example let's
say you're looking at you know lakes in
Wisconsin okay so people are querying
about lakes in Wisconsin and
WolframAlpha they'll name a particular
lake and they want to know you know how
big is the lake
okay fine in Wolfram language they'll be
doing a systematic computation about
lakes in Wisconsin so if there's a lake
missing you're gonna get the wrong
answer and so that's a kind of higher
level of difficulty okay but the this
yeah I think you're asking some more
technical questions about ontologies and
I can try and answer those actually one
quick question and you know that's
there's a lot of other questions yes
that's right okay all right very much my
cyclist as to the left here I got a
simple question who or what are your key
influences oh gosh in terms of language
design for from language are in the
context of machine intelligence if you
like if you want to make it tighter to
this audience I don't know I've been
absorbing stuff forever I think my main
in terms of language design probably
list span APL were my sort of early
influences but in terms of thinking
about AI hmm you know in I mean I'm kind
of quite knowledgeable I like history of
science so I'm pretty knowledgeable
about the the early history of kind of
mathematical logic symbolic kinds of
things I would say okay maybe I can
answer that in the negative okay I have
for example in building Wolfram Alpha I
thought gosh let me do my homework let
me learn all about computational
linguistics let me hire some
computational linguistics PhDs that will
be a good way to get this started
turns out we used almost nothing from
the from the previous sort of history of
computational linguistics partly because
what we were trying to do namely short
question natural language understanding
is different from a lot of the national
language processing which has been was
done in the past I also have made to my
disappointment very little use of you
know people like Marvin Minsky for
example I really don't think I mean I
knew Marvin for years and in fact some
of his early work on simple Turing
machines and things those are probably
more influential to me than his work on
on AI and you know probably
I my mistake of not understanding that
better but really I would say that I'd
been been rather uninfluenced by by sort
of the traditional AI kinds of things I
mean it probably hasn't helped that I've
kind of lived through a time when when
sort of AI went from you know when I was
a kid a I was gonna solve everything in
the world and then you know it kind of
decayed for a while and then sort of
come back so I so I would say that I can
describe my negative my non influences
better than my impression you gave is
that you made your own head and it
sounds as though that's pretty much
right yeah I mean yes I I mean insofar
as those things to me I mean look things
like the you know okay so for example
studying simple programs as and trying
to understand the universe of simple
programs actually the personal history
of that sort of interesting I mean I you
know I used to do particle physics when
I was a kid basically and then I
actually got interested okay so I'll
totally the history of that just as an
example of how sort of interesting is a
sort of history of ideas type thing so I
was interested in in how order arises in
the universe so you know you start off
from the hot Big Bang and then pretty
soon you end up with a bunch of humans
and galaxies and things like this how
does this happen so I got on just in
that question I was also interested in
in things like knowing that works for
sort of AI purposes and I thought let me
make a minimal model that encompasses
sort of how complex things arise from
from other stuff and I ended up sort of
making simpler and simpler and simpler
models and eventually wound up with
cellular automata and which I didn't
know were called cellular automata when
I started looking at them and then found
they didn't interesting things and the
two areas were cellular automata had
been singularly unuseful in analyzing
things our large-scale structure in the
universe and neural networks so turned
out but but that by the way the fact
that I kind of even imagined that one
could just start yeah I should say you
know I've been doing physics and in
physics the kind of intellectual concept
is you take the world as it is and you
try and drill down and find out what you
know what makes the world out of
primitives and so on it's
you know reduce to find things then I
built my first computer language a thing
called SMP which went the other way
around where I was just like I'm just
gonna make up this computer language and
you know just make up what I want the
primitives to be and I'm gonna build
stuff up from it I think that the fact
that I kind of had the idea of doing
things like making up cellular automata
as possible models for the world was a
consequence of the fact that I worked on
this computer language which was a thing
which worked the opposite way around
from the way that one is used to doing
natural science which is sort of this
reductionist approach and that's I mean
so that's just an example of it you know
I found I happen to have spent a bunch
of time studying as I say history of
science and one of my one of my hobbies
is sort of history of ideas I even wrote
this little book called idea makers
which is about biographies of a bunch of
people who for one reason or another
I've written about and so I'm I'm always
curious about this thing about how do
people actually wind up figuring out the
things they figure out and you know one
of the one of the conclusions of my you
know investigations of many people is
there are very rarely moments of
inspiration usually it's long
multi-decade kinds of things which only
later get compressed into something
short and also the path is often much
you know it's it's it's quite what can I
say
that the steps are quite small and you
know but the path is often kind of
complicated and that's what that's what
it's been for me so I simple question
complex answer sorry so when I basically
see from the Wolfram languages it's a
way to describe all of objective reality
it's kind of formalizing just about the
entire domain of discourse use a
philosophical term and you kind of
hinted at this in your lecture where
that where it sort of leaves office is
that when we start to talk about more
esoteric philosophical concepts purpose
I guess this would lean into things like
epistemology because essentially you
only have science there and as amazing
as Sciences there are other things that
are talked about not you know you know
like idealism versus materialism etc do
you have an idea of how Wolfram might or
might not be able to branch into those
discourses because I'm
hearing echoes in my head at that time
boström said that nai needs a you know
when you give an AI a purpose there's
like I think he said philosophers are
divided completely evenly between the
top four ways to measure how good
something should be it's like
utilitarianism and sure brother for most
Japanese yeah so the first thing is I
mean this problem of making what okay
about 300 years ago people like light
knits we're interested in the same
problem that I'm interested in which is
how do you formalize sort of everyday
discourse and Leibniz had the original
idea you know he was originally trained
as a lawyer and he had this idea if he
could only reduce all law all legal
questions to matters of logic he could
have a machine that would basically
describe every you know answer every
legal case right he was unfortunately a
few hundred years too early even though
he did have you know he tried to he
tried to do all kinds of things very
similar things I've tried to do like he
tried to get various Dukes to assemble
big libraries of data and stuff like
this but but the point so what he tried
to do was to make a formalized
representation of everyday discourse for
whatever reason for the last 300 years
basically people haven't tried to do
that there's it's a almost completely
barren landscape there was this period
of time in the 1600s when people talked
about philosophical languages Leibniz
was why and a guy called John Wilkins
was another and they tried to you know
break down human thought into something
symbolic people haven't done that for a
long time in terms of what can we do
that with you know I've been trying to
figure out what the best way to do it is
I think it's actually not as hard as one
might think these areas one thing you
have to understand these areas like
philosophy and so on are they're on the
harder end I mean things like a good
example typical example you know I want
to have a piece of chocolate okay they
in morphing language right now we have a
pretty good description of pieces of
chocolate we know all sorts of you know
we probably know 100 different kinds of
chocolate we know how big the pieces are
all that kind of thing the I want part
of that sentence we can't do that right
now but I don't think that's that hard
and I'm you know that's now if you ask
let's say we had I think the different
thing you're saying is let's say we had
the omnipotent AI so to speak that was
able to you know where we turn over the
control of the central bank to the AI we
turn over all these other things to the
AI then the question is we say to the AI
now do the right thing and then the
problem with that is and this is why I
talk about you know creating AI
constitutions and so on we have
absolutely no idea what do the right
thing is supposed to mean and
philosophers have been arguing about
that you know utilitarianism is an
example of that of one of the answers to
that although it's not a complete answer
by any means it's not not really an
answer it's just a way of posing the
question and so I think that the you
know one of one of the features of so I
think it's a really hard problem to you
know you think to yourself what should
the AI Constitution actually say so
first thing you might think is oh
there's going to be you know something
like Asimov's laws of robotics there's
going to be one you know golden rule for
a eyes and if we just follow that golden
rule all well okay I think that that is
absolutely impossible and in fact I
think you can even sort of
mathematically prove that that's
impossible because I think as soon as
you have a system that you know
essentially what you're trying to do is
you're trying to put in constraints that
okay basically as soon as you have a
system that shows computational
irreducibility I think it is inevitable
that you have ace of have unintended
consequences of things which means that
you never get to just say put everything
in this one very nice box you always
have to say let's put in a patch here
let's put in a patch there and so on a
version of this much more abstract
version of this of girdles theorem so
girdles theorem is you know it starts up
by taking the you know it's girls
theorem is trying to talk about integers
it says start off with piano's axioms
turner's axioms you might say in piano
thought describe the integers and
nothing but the integers okay so
anything that's provable from pianos
axioms will be true about integers and
vice-versa okay
what girls theorem shows is that you can
that will never work that there are an
infinite
hierarchy of patches that you have to
put on two pianos axioms if you want to
describe the integers and nothing about
the integers and I think the same is
true if you want to have a legal system
effectively that has no bizarre
unintended consequences so I don't think
it's possible to just say you know if
you when you're describing something in
the world that's complicated like I
don't think it's possible to just have a
small set of rules that will always do
what we want so to speak I think it's
inevitable that you have to have a long
essentially code of laws and that's what
you know so my guess is that what will
actually have to happen is you know as
we try and describe what you want the
eyes to do you know I don't know the
socio-political aspects of how we'll
figure out whether it's 1 AI
Constitution or 1 per you know city or
whatever we can talk about that that's a
separate issue but but um you know I
think what will happen is it'll be much
like human laws it'll be a complicated
thing that gets progressively patched
and so I think it's it's some and these
ideas like you know oh we'll just make
the eyes you know run the world
according to you know Mills you know
John Stuart Mill's idea it's not gonna
work which is not surprising this
philosophy has has has made the point
that it's not as easy it's not an easy
problem for the last two thousand years
and they're right it's not an easy
problem thank you yeah I you're talking
about computational irreducibility and
computational equivalents and also that
earlier on in your intellectual
adventures you're interested in particle
physics and things like that I've heard
you make the comment before in other
contexts that things like molecules
compute and I was just ask you exactly
you you know what you mean by that in
what sense does a molecule I mean what
would you like to compute so to speak I
mean in other words you what what is the
case is that you know one definition of
you're computing is given a particular
computation like I don't know finding
square roots or something you know you
can program a you know
the surprising thing is that an awful
lot of stuff can be programmed to do any
computation you want that's some and you
know when it comes to I mean I think for
example when you look at nanotechnology
and so on the the current you know one
of the current beliefs says to make very
small computers you should take what we
know about making big computers and just
you know make them smaller so to speak I
don't think that's the approach you have
to use I think you can take the
components that exist at the level of
molecules and say how do we assemble
those components to be able to do
complicated computations I mean it's
like the cellular automata that the you
know the underlying rule for the
cellular automaton is very simple yet
when that rule is applied many times it
can do a sophisticated computation so I
think that that's the that's the sense
in which what can I say the raw material
that you need for computation can be you
know there's a great diversity in the
raw material that you can use for
computation our particular human
development you know stack of of
technologies that we use for computation
right now is just one particular path
and we can you know so a very practical
example of this is algorithmic drugs so
the question is right now drugs pretty
much work by most drugs work well you
know there is a binding site and a
molecule drug fits into binding site
does something question is can you
imagine having something where the
molecule you know is something which has
computations going on in it where it
goes around and it looks at that you
know that thing it's supposed to be
binding to and it figures out oh there's
this knob here and that knob there it
reconfigures itself it's computing
something it's trying to figure out you
know is this likely to be a tumor cell
or whatever based on some more
complicated thing that's the type of
thing that I mean by by computations
happening at an R color scale okay I
guess I meant to ask if it follows from
that if in your view like the the
molecules in the chalkboard and in my
face and in the table are in any sense
currently during doing computer I mean
the question of what computation look
one of the things to realize if you look
at kind of the sort of past and future
of things the the
okay so here's an observation actually I
was about light nets actually and
lightning says time live Nets made a
calculator type computer out of brass
took him 30 years okay so in his day
there was you know at most one computer
in the world as far as he was concerned
right today's world there may be 10
billion computers maybe 20 billion
computers I don't know the question is
what's that going to look like in the
future and I think the answer is that in
time probably everything we have will be
made of computers in the following sense
that basically it won't be you know in
today's world things are made of you
know metal plastic whatever else but
actually that won't make it there won't
be any point in doing that once we know
how to do you know molecular scale
manufacturing and so on we might as well
just make everything out of programmable
stuff and I think that's a that's a
sense in which you know the the and you
know the one example we have molecular
computing right now is us bio in biology
you know biology does a reasonable job
of specific kinds of molecular computing
it's kind of embarrassing I think that
the only you know molecule we know that
sort of a memory molecule is DNA that's
kind of you know which is kind of the
you know the particular biological
solution in time we'll know lots of
others and you know I think the the sort
of the the end point is so if you're
asking is you know is computation going
on in you know in this water bottle the
answer is absolutely it's probably even
many aspects of that computation are
pretty sophisticated if we wanted to
know what would happen to particular
molecules here it's going to be hard to
tell there's going to be computational
irreducibility and so on can we make use
of that for our human purposes can we
piggyback on that to achieve something
technological that's different issue and
that's the four that we have to build up
this whole sort of chain of technology
to be able to connect it which is what
I've kind of been been keep on talking
about is how do we connect sort of what
is possible computationally in the
universe to what we humans can kind of
conceptualize that we want to do in
computation and that's you know that's
the bridge that we have to make and
that's the hard part but getting the
intrinsic getting the computation done
is is you know there's computation going
on all over the place there may be a
couple more questions
I was hoping you could elaborate on what
you're talking about earlier of like
searching the entire space of possible
programs so that's very broad so maybe
like what kind of searching of that
space we're good at and like what we're
not and I guess what the outright so I
mean I would say that we're at an early
stage in knowing how to do that okay so
I've done lots of these things and they
are the thing that I've noticed is if
you do an exhaustive search then you
don't miss even things that you weren't
looking for if you do a non exhaustive
search there is a tremendous tendency to
miss things that you weren't looking for
and so you know we've done such as a
bunch of the function evaluation and
Wolfram language is done by was done by
searching for optimal approximations in
some big space a bunch of stuff with
hashing is done that way bunch of image
processing is done that way what we're
just sort of searching this you know
doing exhaustive searches and maybe
trillions of programs to find things now
you know there is on the other side of
that story is the incremental
improvements story with with deep
learning and neural networks and so on
where because there is differentiable
'ti you're able to sort of incrementally
get to a better solution now in fact
people are making less and less
differentiability and deep learning
neural nets and so I think eventually
there's going to be sort of a grand
unification of these kinds of approaches
right now we're still you know I don't
really know what the you know the
exhaustive search side of things which
you can use for all sorts of purposes I
mean there's the reason the surprising
thing that makes you is also search not
crazy is that there is rich
sophisticated stuff near at hand in the
computational universe if you had to go
you know quadrillions you know through a
quadrillion cases before you ever found
anything the exhaustive search will be
hopeless but you don't in many cases and
you know I would say that we are in a
fairly primitive stage of the science of
how to do those searches well my guess
is that there'll be some sort of
unification which needless to say I've
thought a bunch of
out and between kind of than known that
so you know the trade-off typically in
Iran that says you can have an Iran that
that is very good at that is you know
uses its computational resources well
but it's really hard to train or you can
have an Iran that that doesn't use its
computational resources so well but it's
very easy to train but this is very you
know smoothly and you know my guess is
that somewhere in the you know harder to
train but makes use of things that are
closer to the complete computational
universe is is where one's going to see
progress but it's it's a it's a really
interesting area and you know I consider
us only at the at the beginning of
figuring that out thank you for your
talk I just to give you a bit of context
for my question I research how we could
teach AI to kids and evolving platforms
for that how we could teach artificial
intelligence and machine learning to
children and I know you develop
resources for that as well so I was
wondering like where do you think it's
problematic that we have computation
that is very efficient and can do you
know from utilitarian and problem
solving perspective it's all the goals
but we don't understand how we how it
works so we have to create the this fake
steps and if you could think of
scenarios where that could become very
problematic over time and why do we
approach it such in such a deterministic
way and when you mentioned that
computation and intelligence are dafair
differentiated by this like very thin
line how does that affect the way you
learn and how do you think that will
affect the way we kids learn we learn
right so I mean look my general
principle about you know future
generations and what they should learn I
mean first point is you know very
obvious point that you know for every
field that people study you know
archeology to zoology there either is
now a computational X or there will be
soon
so you know every field the paradigm of
computation is becoming important
perhaps the dominant paradigm in that
field okay so how do you teach kids to
be useful in a world where everything is
computational I think the the number one
thing is to
each them how to think in computational
terms what does that mean that doesn't
mean writing code necessarily I mean in
other words one of the things that's
happening right now as a practical
matter is you know they've been these
waves of enthusiasm for teaching coding
of various kinds you know we're in a
we're not actually we're in the end of
an uptick wave I think it's going down
again um you know it's been up and down
for 40 years or so um okay why doesn't
that work well it doesn't work because
while there are people like people who
are students at MIT for example for whom
they really want to learn you know
engineering style coding and it really
makes sense to them to learn that the
vast majority of people it's just not
going to be relevant because they're not
going to write a low-level C program or
something and it's the same thing that's
happened in math education which has
been sort of a disaster there which is
the number one takeaway for most people
from the math they learn in school is I
don't like math and you know that's not
for all of them obviously but that's the
you know if you asked no general scale
you know what people and why is that
well part of the reason is because
what's been taught is rather low level
of mechanical it's not about
mathematical thinking particularly it's
mostly about you know what teachers can
teach and what assessment processes can
assess and so on okay so how should one
teach computational thinking I mean I'm
I'm kind of excited about what we can do
with whorfin language because I think we
have a high enough level language that
people can actually write you know that
for example I I reckon by age 11 or 12
and I've done many experiments on this I
have some the only problem with my
experiments is most of my experiments
end up being with kids who are high
achieving kids despite many efforts to
reach lower achieving kids that always
ends up that the kids who actually do
the things that I set up or the high
achieving kids but but you know like
setting that aside
you know you take the typical you know
11 12 13 year-olds and so on and they
can learn how to write stuff in this
language and what's interesting is they
learn to start thinking here I'll show
you let's be very practical I can show
you I was doing every Sunday I do a
little little thing with some middle
school
kids and I might even be able to find my
stuff from yesterday this is this is um
okay let's see
programming adventures Janerio 28 okay
let's see what I did
oh look at that that was that was why I
thought of the South America thing here
because I just done that with these kids
the and so what are we doing we were
trying to figure out this this some
trying to figure out the shortest tour
thing like that I just showed you which
is this is where I got what you is is
what I was doing with these kids but
this this was my version of this but the
kids all had various different versions
of this and we had somebody suggested
you know let's just enumerate let's just
look at all possible permutations of
these these cities and figure out what
their distances are there's the
histogram of those that's what we get
from those okay how do you get the
largest distance from those etcetera
etcetera and this is okay this was my
version of it but the kids had similar
stuff and this is you know this is I
think and it probably went off into oh
yeah there we go there's there's the one
for the whole whole earth and then they
wanted to know how do you do that in 3d
so I was showing them how to convert to
XYZ coordinates in 3d and make the
corresponding thing in 3d so what's this
maybe isn't the this is a random example
from yesterday so it's not not a highly
considered example but but um what I
think is interesting is that we seem to
have finally reached the point where
we've automated enough of the actual
doing of the computation that the kids
can be exposed mostly to thinking about
what you might want to compute and you
know part of our role in language design
as far as I'm concerned is to get it as
much as possible to the point where for
example you can do a bunch of natural
language input you can do things which
make it as easy as possible for kids to
not get mixed up in the kind of what the
you know how the computation gets done
but rather to just think about how you
formulate the computation so for example
a typical example I've used much times
in you know what does it mean to do
write code versus two other
things like a typical set of test
example would be I don't know you ask
somebody you're gonna there's practical
problem we had in wolf's mouth you give
a lat long position on the earth and you
say you're gonna make a map of that like
long position what what scale of map
should you make alright so if the
lat/long is in the middle of the Pacific
making a ten mile
you know radius map isn't very
interesting if it's in the middle of
Manhattan a 10-mile radius map might be
quite quite a sensible thing to do so
the question is come up with an
algorithm come up with even a way of
thinking about that question what do you
do you know how should you figure that
out well you might say you know oh let's
look at the visual complexity of the
image let's look at how far it is to
another city let's fight you know there
various different things but thinking
about that as a kind of computational
thinking exercise that term is you know
that's the kind of thing so in terms of
what one automates and whether people
whether people need to understand how it
works inside okay main point is you'll
in the end it will not be possible to
know how it works inside so you might as
well stop having that be a criterion I
mean that is there plenty of things that
one teaches people that let's say in
lots of areas of biology medicine
whatever else you know maybe we'll know
how it works inside one day but you can
still there's an awful lot of useful
stuff you can teach without knowing how
it works inside and I think also as we
get computation to be more efficient
inevitably we will be dealing with
things where you don't know how it works
inside now you know we've seen this in
math education because I've happened to
made tools that automate a bunch of
things that people do in math education
and I think well to tell a silly story
I'm in my my older daughter who at some
point in the past was doing you know
calculus you know and learning doing
integrals and things and I was saying to
her you know I didn't think humans still
did that stuff anymore which was a very
unintelligent fit but in any case I mean
the the you know there's a question of
whether do humans need to know how to do
that stuff or not so I haven't done an
integral by hand and probably thirty
five years
a true more or less true then but when I
was using computers to do them the I was
for a while you know I used to do
physics and so I used computers to do
this stuff I was a really really good
integrator except that it wasn't really
me it was me plus the computer so how
did that come to be
well the answer was that because I was
doing things by computer I was able to
try zillions of examples and I got a
much better intuition the most people
got for how these things would work
roughly how what you did to make the
thing go and so on whereas people who
are like I'm just working this one thing
out by hand
you got a different you know you don't
get that intuition so I think you know
two points first of all you know this
how do you think about things
computationally how do you formulate the
question computationally that's really
important and something that we are now
in a position I think to actually teach
and it is not really something you teach
by you know teaching you know
traditional quotes coding because a lot
of that is okay we're gonna make a loop
we're going to define variables I just
as I think I probably have a copy here
yeah they I wrote this book for this is
a book kind of for kids about often
language except it seems to be useful to
adults as well but I wrote it for kids
so it's some and one of the amusing
things in this book is it doesn't
talking it talked about assigning values
to variables until chapter 38 so in
other words that will be a thing that
you would find in Chapter one of most
you know low-level programming coding
type type things turns out it's not that
relevant to know how to do that it's
also kind of confusing and not necessary
and so you know in terms of the you
asked where will we get in trouble when
people don't know how the stuff works
inside that's I mean you know I think
one just has to get used to that because
it's like you know you might say well we
live in the world and it's full of
natural processes where we don't know
how they work inside but somehow we
manage to survive and we go to a lot of
effort to do natural science to try and
figure out how stuff works inside but it
turns out we can still use plenty of
things even when we don't know how they
work inside we don't need to know
and I think the May I think the main
point is computational irreducibility
guarantees that we will be using things
where we don't know and can't know how
they work inside and you know I think
the the perhaps the thing that is a
little bit you know to me a little bit
unfortunate as a you know as a typical
human type thing the fact that I can
readily see that you know the AI stuff
we build is sort of effectively creating
languages and things that are completely
outside our domain to understand and
we're by that I mean you know our human
language with its fifty thousand words
or whatever has been developed over the
last however many you know tens of
thousands of years and as a society
we've developed this way of
communicating and explaining things you
know the AIS are reproducing that
process very quickly but they're coming
up with a and a historical you know
something you know their way of
describing the world that doesn't happen
to relate at all to our historical way
of doing it and that's you know it's a
little bit disquieting to me as a human
that that you know there are things
going on inside where I know it is you
know in principle I could learn that
language but it's you know not the
historical one that we've all learnt and
it really wouldn't make a lot of sense
to do that because you learn it for one
AI and then another one gets trained and
it's going to use something different so
it's some but my main I guess my main
point for for education another point
about education I just make which is
something I haven't figured out but but
um just is you know when do we get to
make a good model for the human learner
using machine learning so in other words
you know part of what we're trying to do
like like I've got that automated proof
I would really like to manage to figure
out a way what is the best way to
present that proof so a human can
understand it and basically for that we
have to have a bunch of heuristics about
how humans understand things so as an
example if we're doing let's say a lot
of visualization stuff in welcomed
language okay we have tried to automate
do automated aesthetics so what we're
doing is you know we're laying out a
graph what way of laying out that graph
is most likely for humans to understand
and we've done that you know by building
a bunch of heuristics and so on but
that's an example of you know if we
could do that for learning and we say
what's the optimal path given that the
person is trying to understand this
proof for example what's the optimal
path to lead them through understanding
that proof I suspect we will learn a lot
more in probably a fairly small number
of years about that and it will be the
case that you know for example if you've
got oh I don't know you can do simple
things like you know you go to Wikipedia
and you look at what the path of you
know how do you if you want to learn
this concept what other concepts you
have to learn we have much more detailed
symbolic information about what is
actually necessary to know in order to
understand this and so on it is I think
reasonably likely that we will be able
to I mean you know if I look at I was
interested recently in the history of
math education so I wanted to look at
the complete sort of path of math
textbooks you know for the past well
basically the like twelve hundred you
know people actually produced this one
of the early math textbooks so they've
been these different ways of teaching
math and you know I think we've we've
gradually evolved a fairly optimized way
for the typical person though it's
probably the variation of the population
is not well understood for you know how
to explain certain concepts and we've
gone through some pretty weird ways of
doing it from the 1600s and so on
where which have gone out of style and
possibly you know who knows whether
that's versus because of well but anyway
so so you know we've kind of learnt this
path of what's the optimal way to
explain adding fractions or something
for humans for the typical human but I
think we'll learn a lot more about how
you know by by essentially making a
model for the human a machine model for
the human we'll learn more about how to
you know how to optimize how to explain
stuff to humans a coming attraction but
Tim thanks by the way do you think we're
close to that at all because you you
said that there's a something in Wolfram
Alpha that that presents the human a
nice way are we how far said attraction
yeah right so I mean in in that
explaining stuff to humans thing is a
lot of human work right now being able
to automate
explaining stuff to humans okay so some
of these things let's see I mean so an
interesting question actually just today
I was working on something that's
related to this yeah it's it's it's
being able to the question is given a
whole bunch of can we for example train
a machine learning system from
explanations that it can see roughly can
we train it to give explanations that
are likely to be understandable maybe I
think the okay so an example that I'd
like to do okay I'd like to do a
debugging assistant where the typical
thing is program runs program gives
wrong answer human says why did you get
the wrong why did it give the wrong
answer well the first piece of
information to the computer is that was
the human thought that was the wrong
answer because the computer just did
what it was told and it didn't know that
was supposed to be the wrong answer so
then the question is can you in fact you
know in that domain can you actually
have a reasonable conversation in which
the human is explaining the computer
what they thought it was supposed to do
the computer is explaining what happened
and why did it happen and so on same
kind of thing for math tutoring you know
we have a lot of you know we've got a
lot of stuff you know we're sort of very
widely used for people who want to
understand the steps in math you know
can we make a thing where people tell us
I think it's this okay I'll tell you one
one little factoid which I which you did
work out so if you do multi digit
arithmetic multi-digit addition okay
okay so the basis of this is its kind of
silly silly thing but you know if you
get the right answer for an addition
some okay you don't get very much
information the student gives the wrong
answer the question is can you tell them
where they went wrong so let's say you
have a four digit addition sum and the
student gives the wrong answer can you
back trace and figure out what they
likely did wrong and the answer is you
can you know you just make this graph of
all the different things that can happen
you know when did they you know there's
certain things that are more common
transposing numbers and things or you
know having a 1 and a 7 mixed up those
kinds of things you can with very high
power let's say given a for de division
some with the wrong answer you can say
this is the mistake you made
which is sort of interesting and that's
you know being done in a fairly symbolic
way whether one can do that in a you
know more machine learning kind of way
for more complicated derivations I'm not
sure but that's a that's one that works
are you sir I just had a follow-up
question so do you think you know like
in the future this is it possible to
simulate virtual environments which can
actually understand how the human mind
works and then build you know like
finite state machines inside of this
virtual environment to provide a better
learning experience and a more
personalized learning experience well I
mean so the question is if if you're
going to you know can you optimize if
you're playing a video game or something
and that video game is supposed to be
educational can you optimize the the
experience based on a model of you so to
speak yeah I'm sure the answer is yes
and I'm sure the you know the question
of how complicated the model of you will
be is an interesting question I don't
know the answer to I mean I've I've kind
of wanted a similar question so I I'm a
kind of personal analytics enthusiast so
I collect tons of data about myself and
I mean I do it mostly because it's been
super easy to do and I've done it for
like 30 years and I have you know every
keystroke I've typed on a computer like
every keystroke I've typed here and I
the screen of my computer every every 30
seconds or so of maybe 15 seconds I'm
not sure it there's a screen shot it's a
super boring movie to watch but anyway
I've been collecting all this stuff and
so a question that I've asked is is
there enough data that a bot of me could
be made in other words do I have enough
data about you know I've got I've
written a million emails I have all of
those I've received three million emails
over that period of time I've got you
know endless you know things I've typed
etc etcetera etcetera you know is there
enough data to reconstruct you know me
basically I think the answer is probably
yes not sure but I think the answer is
probably yes and so the question is in
an environment where you are interacting
with some video game trying to learn
something whatever else you know
how long is it going to be before it can
learn enough about you to change that
environment in a way that's useful for
explaining the next thing to you I would
guess I would guess that have done that
this is comparatively easy I might be
wrong but that and that the I mean I
think you know it's an interesting thing
because you know once dealing with you
know there's a space of human
personalities there's a space of human
learning styles you know I'm sort of
always interested in the space of all
possible XYZ and there's you know
there's that question over how do you
parameterize the space of all possible
human learning styles and is there a way
that we will learn you know like can we
do that symbolically and say these are
ten learning styles or is it something I
think that's a case where it's better to
use you know sort of soft machine
learning type methods to kind of feel
out that space well you know maybe very
last question I was just intuitively
thinking when you spoke about an ocean I
thought of Isaac Newton when he said I
mean you know the famous quote I might
not and I thought instead of Newton on
the beach what if franz liszt were there
what question would he ask what would he
say
and I'm trying to understand you're the
alien ocean and humans through maybe
Franz Liszt and music well so I mean the
the quote from Newton is is some sort of
an interesting quote I think it goes
something like this if you know people
are talking about how wonderful calculus
and all that kind of thing are and
Newton says you know to others I may
seem like I've done a lot of stuff but
to me I seem like a child who who picked
up a particularly elegant you know
seashell on the on the beach and I've
been studying this this seashell for a
while even though there's this ocean of
truth out there waiting to be discovered
that's roughly the quote okay
I find that quote interesting for the
following reason the what Newton did was
you know calculus and things like
kit if you look at the computational
universe of all possible programs there
is a small corner Newton was exactly
right and what he said that is he picked
off calculus which is a corner of the
possible things that can happen in the
computational universe that happened to
be an elegant seashell so to speak they
happened to be a case where you can
figure out what's going on and and so on
while there is still a sort of ocean of
of other sort of computational
possibilities out there but but when it
comes to you know you're asking about
music I I think my computer stopped
being able to get anywhere but but um
sort of interesting the cific get to the
site yeah so this is a this is a website
that we made years ago and now my
computer isn't playing anything but
[Music]
let's try that okay so these things are
created by basically just searching
computational universe for possible
programs it's sort of interesting
because everyone has kind of a story
some of them are look more interesting
than others let's try that one
anyway the the what's what's interesting
actually what was interesting to me
about this was this is a very trivial
you know what this is doing is very
trivial at some level it's just it
actually happens to use cellular
automata you can even have it show you I
think someplace here where is it
somewhere there's a way of showing your
show the evolution this is this is
showing the behind the scenes what was
actually happening what it chose to use
to generate that musical piece um and
what I thought was interesting about the
site I thought well you know how would
computers be relevant to music etcetera
etcetera etcetera well you know what
would happen is a human would have an
idea and then the computer would kind of
dressup that idea and then you know a
bunch of years go by and I talked to
people you know who composers and things
and they say oh yeah I really like that
wolfram tones site okay that's nice they
say it's a very good place for me to get
ideas so that's sort of the opposite of
what I would have expected namely what's
happening is you know human comes here
you know listens to some 10-second
fragment and they said oh that's an
interesting idea and then they kind of
embellish it using kind of something
that is humanly meaningful but it's like
you know you're taking a photograph and
you see some interesting configuration
and then kind of you're you know you're
filling that with kind of some human
sort of context but but so I'm not quite
sure what what you were asking about I I
mean back to the Newton quote the thing
that I think is some another way to
think about that quote is us humans you
know with our sort of historical
development of you know our intellectual
history have explored this very small
corner of what's possible in the
computational universe and everything
that we care about is contained in the
small corner and that means that you
know you could say well gee you know I
want to you know what we what we end up
wanting to talk about other things that
we as a society
have decided we care about and what
there's an interesting feedback loop I
just mentioned mr. den but but um so you
might say so here's a funny thing so
let's take language for example language
evolves we you say we we make up
language to describe what we see in the
world okay fine
that's a fine idea imagine the you know
in Paleolithic times people make up
language they probably didn't have a
word for table because they didn't have
any tables they probably had a word for
rock but then we end up as a result of
the particular you know development that
our civilization has gone through we
build tables and there was sort of a
synergy between coming up with a word
for table and deciding tables were a
thing and we should build a bunch of
them and so there's a sort of
complicated interplay between the things
that we learn how to describe and how to
think about the things that we build and
put in our environment and then the
things that we end up wanting to talk
about because they're things that we
have experience of in our environment
and so that's the you know I think as we
look at sort of the progress of
civilization there's you know there's
various layers of first we you know we
invent a thing that we can then think
about and talk about then we build an
environment based on that then that
allows us to do more stuff and we build
on top of that and that's why for
example when we talk about computational
thinking and teaching it to kids and so
on that's one reason that's kind of
important because we're building a layer
of things that people are then familiar
with that's different from what we've
had so far and they give people a way to
talk about things I give you one example
that um see that I have that still up
the okay one one one example here from
this blog post of mine actually so there
okay so that that thing there is a
nested pattern you know it's a bitter
sierpinski that that tile pattern was
created in 1210 ad okay and it's the
first example I know of a fractal
pattern okay
well the art historians wrote about
these patterns they're a bunch of this
particular style of pattern they wrote
about these for years they never
discussed that nested pattern these
patterns also have you know pictures of
lions and then you know elephants and
things like that on them they wrote
about those kinds of things but they
never mentioned the nested pattern until
basically about 25 years ago when
fractals and so on became a thing and
then it's ah I can now talk about that
it's a nested pattern it's fractal and
then you know before that time the art
historians were blind to that particular
part of this pattern it's just like I
don't know what that is that there's no
you know I don't have a word to describe
it I'm not going to I'm not going to
talk about it so that's a you know it's
part of this feedback loop of things
that we we learn to describe then we
build in terms of those things then we
build another layer I think one of the
things I mean you talk about you know
just in the sort of the thing like one
thing I'm really interested in is the
evolution of purposes so you know if you
look back in human history there's a you
know what was thought to be worth doing
a thousand years ago it's different from
what's thought to be worth doing today
and part of that is is you know good
examples of things like you know walking
on a treadmill or buying goods in
virtual worlds both of these are hard to
explain to somebody from a thousand
years ago because each one ends up being
a whole sort of societal story about
we're doing this because we do that
because we do that and so the question
is how will these purposes evolve in the
future and I think one of the things
that I view as a sort of sobering
thought is that that term actually one
thing I found other disappointing and
then I became less pessimistic about it
is if you think about the future of the
human condition and you know we've been
successful in making our AI systems and
we can read out brains and we can upload
consciousnesses and things like that and
we've eventually got this box with
trillions of souls and
and the question is what are these souls
doing and to us today it looks like
they're playing video games to the rest
of eternity right and that seems like a
kind of a bad outcome it's like we've
gone through all of this long history
and what do we end up with we end up
with a trillion souls in a box playing
video games okay um and I thought this
is a very you know depressing outcome so
to speak and then I realized that that
actually you know if you look at the
sort of arc of human history people
aren't any given time in history people
have been you know they've my main
conclusion is that any time in history
the things people do seem meaningful and
purposeful to them at that time in
history and history moves on and you
know like a thousand years ago there
were a lot of purposes that people had
that you know what to do with weird
superstitions and things like that that
we say why the heck are you doing that
that just doesn't make any sense
right but to them at that time it made
all the sense in the world and I think
that you know the thing that makes me
sort of less depressed about the future
so to speak is that at any given time in
history you know you can still have
meaningful purposes even though they may
not look meaningful from a different
point in history and that there's sort
of a whole theory you can kind of build
up based on kind of the the trajectories
that you've followed through the space
of purposes and sort of interesting if
you can't jump like you say let's get
chronically frozen for a you know 300
years and then you know be be back again
the the interesting cases then you know
are the purposes that you sort of you
know that you find yourself in ones that
have any continuity with what we know
today
I should stop with that that's a
beautiful way to end it
they Han
[Applause]